first is a DNA vaccine which is called
ad vax which is we first tested I'm 2003
2004 and DNA vaccines are wonderful in
that they are very safe they're cheap
they don't require a cold chain they
work great in mice and they don't work
very well in people so we tested that
and it was modestly immunogenic which is
as good as one might hope for DNA
vaccines but the idea was that would be
combined with at mva which is based on
the smallpox vaccine its modified
vaccinia ankara so we know that the
smallpox vaccine induces good immunity
so the idea like what the adenoviral
vector is to use the smallpox vaccine as
a vector and so that's what we did and
we conducted a trial of that alone and
then a small trial of the two together
those are being moved forward by dr. ho
and his team in China and they're moving
into advanced development so you have
phase 1 trials which is what we
conducted which are largely safety we
also of course looked at immunogenicity
because we're not going to give
something to people and not figure out
if it's doing something and then they
move into larger trials and in order to
move into larger trials you have to move
into a population of people who are
getting infected because you're starting
to look for efficacy so these vaccines
were always designed to move forward for
efficacy trials into China because of
the number of infections in the
developing world versus the United
States most efficacy trials have been
and will continue to be conducted in the
south of the developing world so I I
stay in New York you know I've been to
China a couple of times but my work is
primarily here at the Rockefeller
hospital so currently what I'm working
on which is very exciting and this is
under the rubric of the Grand Challenges
in global health grant mechanism through
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and the eff NIH the foundation for NIH
and brow Steinman how I mentioned 17
million times in this conversation and
is the the intellectual force behind
this in the p.i of the grant and I
the privilege of doing the clinical part
but we are developing a vaccine that
directly targets dendritic cells so i
think i mentioned earlier that for any
vaccine to work we know it has to get to
dendritic cells and you know you can
demonstrate with a lot of them that they
due to greater or lesser degrees but we
sort of decided to take the bull by the
horns and make a vaccine that knows how
to find dendritic cells so it's what's
called rational vaccine design and it's
I think it's brilliant and I can say
that because I didn't think of it I get
to conduct it but I didn't figure it out
the idea is we have a monoclonal
antibody that's directed against what's
called deck 205 and deck 205 is on
dendritic cells it's a marker it's
special on dendritic cells that was
discovered by Ralph and my friend and
colleague Michelle Knussen's like many
years ago so they made an antibody to it
so that antibody goes into the body and
immediately finds that receptor and so
then we've hooked up to that monoclonal
antibody genes are the antigen for HIV
the one we're starting with his gag
which is the core which is conserved in
there lots of reasons that's a good one
to start with so we have a monoclonal
antibody that knows how to find
dendritic cells hooked up to our HIV
antigen and this is a protein and so
we've been moving that concept forward
in small animals and now we are going to
be moving into the clinic and so we have
our first conversation about this with
the FDA in August and I'm hoping that
we'll be in the clinic by year's end so
the idea is we have to be smarter than
nature we can't because natural
infection doesn't confer protection we
have to figure a way around what the
virus that causes AIDS HIV has learned
how to do and to do that we want to
directly target dendritic cells the
cells that we know orchestrate immunity
you